unser sozialer frieden und unsere werte
sind abhängig von unserem wohlstand und
wenn der schmilzt dann werden die nicht
auf gleiche art und weise erhalten
bleiben kann da krachen jetzt systeme
gegeneinander und wir sind als
demokratien da ziemlich angreifbar wenn
man es nicht gut meint im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert da muss
man kein prophet sein über china noch
bedeuten war werden indien wird noch
sehr viel bedeutender werdende bedeutung
amerikas und europas werden klein hat
werden
wenn wir es nicht mehr schaffen in
ländern die direkt an die eu kann
grenzen ja die uns unmittelbar betreffen
einfluss zu nehmen dann denke ich immer
ja was zur hölle war mit dem rest der
welt ausrichten ich glaube dass wir ganz
große probleme im augenblick damit haben
und selbst zu sehen und uns selbst zu
verstehen sondern wir blicken zurück in
etwas das anders war und wir blicken
voraus wenn etwas an dem wir keine
vorstellung haben es sei denn
historische bilder
es gab ja mal eine zeit da da wurden die
demokratien oder die liberalen system
auf der welt wurden einmal mehr
mittlerweile nehmen sie ganz eindeutig
ab
[Musik]
lanz und recht
schönen guten morgen gesichert guten
morgen markus wo erreiche ich dich
ausnahmsweise mal wieder in der kemenate
zu früher stunde am ort lich noch nie
haben wir so früh aufgenommen 8 uhr 18
serien und unterhalten uns über die
weltlage um 880
genau ist eigentlich ein frühaufsteher
geworden geworden ist ja ja ich habe sie
nie level ups oder gerne so wochenende
lange geschlafen ja aber inzwischen
senile bettflucht den ja man denkt so
ein bisschen auch wahrscheinlich so die
innere uhr sagt verweist wie alt man
noch
will ich schon tot
es ist tatsächlich so also dass ich
häufig frühaufsteher ja ich stehe auch
gerne früh auf sich habe deshalb blieb
er später ins bett und das ist in der
kombination nicht gut ich habe das
gefühl gerade die die die der tag
bräuchte mehr als 24 stunden habe ich
schon höre ja wie du weißt auf den
mittagsschlaf ich weiß mit erholt haben
noch mal ein bisschen was raus also wenn
man das nicht macht früh aufstehen das
mache ich ja gerne spät ins bett gehen
mache ich auch gerne aber ohne den
mittagsschlaf ich irgendwie am abend für
nichts mehr zu gebrauchen ja also ich
denke mal über dieses konzept nach
richard in ruhe und wird man versuchen
das irgendwann mal zu beherzigen guck
mal ob du irgendwo in den studios ein
ganz kleines sofa findest auf dass du
dich kuscheln kann bestimmt bestimmt
haben dann würde ich ständig über die
nächste sendung nachdenken und und
allein der gedanke an das nächste
gespräch mit sigmar gabriel würde mich
direkt wieder schlagartig wach sein
ja der immer an spannende
herausforderung der gesprächspartner ist
richtig wir reden über schlaf und einer
der gründe warum wir alle im moment so
wach sind und wenig schlafen nicht in
den schlaf finden und von seiner inneren
unruhe getrieben sind hat glaube ich
fast mit der lage der welt zu tun das
klingt jetzt viel größer als ich das
meine aber dieses individuelle gefühl
der überforderung dieses gefühl nicht
mehr wirklich klar zu kommen dieses
gefühl da passieren dinge und du hast es
plötzlich nicht mehr im griff
alles kommt so über uns und und die
jüngere vergangenheit ist ja auch voll
von solchen beispielen ist das ein
gefühl das du auch teilst ich erlebt
dass wann immer ich mit leuten spreche
habe ich das gefühl keiner weiß im
moment so richtig wo oben und unten ist
und das ist kein guter zustand
also einmal völlig richtig meine ganz
große irritation weil so viele gewaltige
dinge sich parallel ereignet
dann aus einer welt kommt in der sich
nie so viele dinge auf einmal erreichen
getan sondern alles doch vergleichsweise
geruhsame gewesen also in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik hat es so was was es
jetzt gibt noch nicht gegeben dass man
das gefühl hat dass sich die die
plattentektonik vollständig verschiebt
und damit meine ich nicht nur die
geostrategische dass man plötzlich gar
nicht mehr weiß so auf welchem schält
man selber ist was gerade mit der welt
passiert wo das hin driftet dann muss
kann ja auch nicht übersehen die
geschichte der bundesrepublik ist so
eine unglaublich schöne
erfolgsgeschichte alles wurde immer mehr
und vielen leuten ging es immer ein
bisschen besser und es sah so aus als
würde die welt dauerhaft immer
friedlicher werden jedenfalls den teil
der welt den wir so ins hauptaugenmerk
genommen haben weil den anderen haben
wir nicht so hingeguckt aber irgendwo
globalisierung weitet sich aus die
hoffnung macht dem mauerfall die ganze
welt würde irgendwann eine demokratische
wohlstandsgesellschaft der liberalismus
setzt sich durch und jetzt zeugen einer
in einer welt zu sein wo man eine
erfahrung mache die für mich
psychologisch über allen anderen steht
dass man das heft des handelns gar nicht
in hand hat jetzt müssen wir mal eins
dazu sagen muss was meinst du wie viele
länder der welt gibt wo die leute immer
schon dieses gefühl haben mussten der
wolf hier sind es nicht gewohnt wir
haben das gefühl und ich meine mit wir
jetzt nicht nur deutschland nicht meine
entweder europa oder der westen der die
geschicke des planeten bestimmt in guten
wie in weniger guten und jetzt haben wir
das gefühl wir bestimmen das gar nicht
alleine wir bestimmen was vielleicht
viel viel weniger als wir noch vor vier
monaten geglaubt habe und genau und ich
glaube das ist erstmal dass das wohn
macht's gefühl dass einsetzt plötzlich
fühlen wir uns wie ganz andere länder
also länder die ohnehin die das geschick
des planeten bestimmt haben an dass es
so ein bisschen verrückt wenn man war
immer der der champion mann ist völlig
selbstverständlich mit dieser rolle
aufgewachsen und dann weiß man am ende
des jahrhunderts wer weiß was da noch
aus europa kommen sein wird ja und dann
wird china der champion sein oder
vielleicht wird auch ende des
jahrhunderts indien der champion sein
oder indonesien also dinge die wir noch
gar nicht abschätzen können und ich
glaube das hinterlässt eine unglaubliche
unruhe weil das alles länder sind von
denen wir nichts besseres erwarten als
wir von uns selbst erwarten ja genau so
ist es ich habe am wochenende darüber
nachgedacht ich meine allein mit dem
blick auf die gasrechnung und diese
gasrechnung die jetzt gerade kommt ist
mitnichten die die dann wirklich die
schockwellen verbreiten wird
wird einem übel war dann plötzlich klar
wird okay ein zurück zu dem was wir
vorher hatten wird es so nicht mehr
geben und der gedanke dahinter ist
eigentlich und das ist ein bisschen auch
die die persönliche erfahrung meines
lebens
sozialer aufstieg im persönlichen wie
auch auf offener auf einer größeren
ebene sozialer aufstieg ist so viel
einfacher als soziale abstieg also
sozusagen den weg immer weiter nach oben
zu gehen das macht man strengt sich an
und haut sich rein und am ende kommt was
dabei heraus aber mittlerweile ist diese
gewissheit ist ja vor für viele weg also
du hängst dich rein du strengste ich an
du du du wirst dich mit anlauf jeden tag
rein ins getümmel und dieses gefecht
aber mittlerweile und das ist das ist
die andere erfahrung die jüngere leute
hier ist vor allen dingen machen im
gegensatz zu menschen die uns im
gegensatz zu unseren eltern
beispielsweise die wussten relativ
verlässlich wenn man sich richtig
reinhängt dann kommt am ende was gutes
dabei heraus was wird sich gelohnt haben
aber das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr der
fall du hängst dich rein und schmeiß ich
schmeiß dich jeden tag ins gefecht aber
am ende was gutes dabei heraus kommt
oder ob du wirklich den sozialen
aufstieg schafft völlig unklar wobei das
auch eine ganz wichtige potter dass ich
unterschreibe das völlig was du sagst
das sagt aber auch für die aufstiegs
generation der 50er 60er 70er 80er jahre
etwas wichtiges aus was ich auch immer
auf meinen büchern betont habe dass es
mein wirkliches heft in der hand hat
dass man mit seiner eigenen tüchtigkeit
in einem land was werden kann seinen
status verbessern dass wohlstand kommen
sozialausgleich selbst bestimmt nicht
nur von einem selbst ab sondern sich
auch von rahmenbedingungen ab die das
ermöglichen total gut haben es gab ja
einen kollektiven ausstieg also wie
viele sich millionen menschen sind von
der unterschicht in die mittelschicht
zum teil in die gehobene mittelschicht
aufgestiegen
wer all die ingenieure also der
klassische berufsfeld der gymnasiasten
meiner generation deren väter waren
ingenieure aber deren väter waren keine
ingenieure gewesen hatten zum großen
teil auch kein abitur gehabt
dass ihm natürlich damit zusammen das
ist ein unglaublich günstiges
ökonomisches klima gab auch ein
gesellschaftliches klima es gab einen
großen gesellschaftlichen bedarf an all
diesen leuten das wurde auch gefördert
und die tüchtigkeit die haben sie ohne
zweifel gehabt aber sie hatten noch das
glück ihre tüchtigkeit zum richtigen
zeitpunkt am richtigen ort in der welt
ausleben zu können und jetzt merken wir
dass in dem maße in dem sich die
plattentektonik verschiebt diese
erfolgsgeschichten nicht mehr kollektiv
möglich sind das heißt sie sind einzeln
noch möglich der ein oder andere macht
seinen sozialen aufstieg aber es ist ja
nicht mehr so gegen diesem damals
unglaublich gut gedüngten 50er 60er 70er
jahren genau und richtig und wie gesagt
der weg nach oben ist der so viel
bessere als der weg von oben nach unten
also gesellschaften abstiegs
gesellschaften als ein begriff den der
soziologe oliver nachtwey vor ich
schätze jetzt mal so sieben acht jahren
hat ein buch geschrieben die abstiegs
gesellschaft
und es ist natürlich völlig klar also in
gesellschaften in die davon bedroht sind
noch ist das ja nicht wirklich
flächendeckend der fall aber die davon
bedroht sind dass der wohlstand
dauerhaft
abnimmt wir hatten ganz schnell in
stabile gesellschaften
und es ist ja so dass die werte auf die
wir zu recht stolz sind einer im
internationalen und historischen
vergleich sehr gut funktionierenden
gesellschafter in die er natürlich nicht
alles perfekt ist ja in dem es auch
tragische schicksale gibt in denen es
auch soziale ungerechtigkeit nicht ohne
zweifel aber muss das ja alles mal im
vergleich sehen und dass solche
gesellschaften wenn die iren auf dem
hohen ross ihrer werte auf dem ihr
zurecht ja sitzen und auch gerne sitzen
können die ganz schnell auch
runterfallen und unterstützen das heißt
also unser sozialer frieden und unsere
werte sind abhängig von unserem
wohlstand und wenn der schmilzt dann
werden die nicht auf gleiche art und
weise erhalten bleiben können muss
richtig und das ist das dramatisch seien
im ganzen also dass man insgesamt etwas
weniger erwirtschaftet wäre ja sogar aus
ökologischen gründen zwingend notwendig
aber auf der individuellen ebene führt
das zu frust führt das zu enttäuschungen
zu
enttäuschten fairness erwartungen und
das macht sehr viel mit der gesellschaft
das ist sehr gefährlich es ist wirklich
sehr gefährlich und weil das gerade sagt
rich hat muss sich gerade daran denken
es gab in der vergangenen woche einen
einen wirklich bemerkenswerten moment
eine eine frau der nahm man sich merken
muss cassidy hutchinson sagte die
ehemalige mitarbeiterin des stabschefs
markt wieder von von donald trump die im
grunde die zeugin ist eigentlich muss
man diese frau wirklich feiern die
wahren riesen
eine überraschungs zeugen die tramps
putschpläne jetzt rund um den 6 januar
mit dem wir schon öfter hier gesprochen
haben mal enthüllt hat und im grunde
verdanken wir dieser frau junge frau von
25 jahren der verdanken wir eigentlich
dass es heute keine zweifel mehr geben
kann dass trump und seine leute um ihn
herum die wollten tatsächlich diesen
putsch und um ein haar hätte es auch
funktioniert die hat atemberaubende
dinge in der vergangenen woche ausgesagt
zum beispiel dass trump sehr genau sich
darüber im klaren waren dass die leute
die da an kamen dass die andere pläne
hatten als einfach nur eine kleine
demonstration über diese angeblich
geklaute wahl abzuhalten sondern die
wahl zum teil wirklich bis an die zähne
bewaffnet wurden dann von der security
nicht auf den platz gelassen auf dem er
gesprochen hat und er fordert seine
eigenen leute auf die die polizei auf
diese leute durch zulassung sagt die
sind keine bedrohung für mich lasst die
ruhig rein sie erzählt wie der name
braut boys und andere wie dienen die
sind diese namen die die namen der
anführer wird das tagelang wochenlang
vorher schon im weißen haus diskutiert
worden ist sie schildert eine szene du
kennst kannst
julian ideen war eigentlich legendären
bürgermeister von new york der dann
irgendwann völlig falsch abgebogen ist
und er am 2 januar auf einem parkplatz
in washington zu around und sagt cassidy
freust du dich eigentlich auf den
sechsten januar und sie sagt was soll
denn da passieren untersagt da werden
dinge passieren da kommen unsere leute
und bereitet sie eigentlich auf diesen
auf diesen sturm quasi aufs kapital vor
und sie berichtet dann wenig später
ihrem chef dem stabschef magneto darüber
und der sagt ja das wird passieren ein
paar
beunruhigende dinge da könnte
es könnte schlimm werden am 6 januar
sagt der und da erzählt sie wie sie das
erste mal angst bekommt schildert szenen
wie tom als dann seine eigene
justizminister im fernsehen interviews
gibt und sagt nee diese war die sga ich
geklaut worden vor wut seinen seinen
teller mit dem burger und dem ketchup
wie gegen eine wand im weißen haus ball
hat und wie sie dann die ganze
ketchup
bürgergeld gemisch irgendwie von der
wand wieder runter kratzen solche szenen
haben sich da abgespielt und trank
selber hatte diesen plan der wollte
dahinter wollte seinen eigenen fahrer
die die security dazu bringen ihn
dorthin zu fahren auch zum kapitol und
wurde von seinen eigenen leuten mit mühe
so schildert sie das davon abgehalten
hat dem fahrer offensichtlich ins
lenkrad gegriffen weil er ihn dahin
lenken wollte und so weiter das hatte
offenbar wenn stimmt was diese frau sagt
und das hat sie sehr glaubwürdig erzählt
das hatte alles einen staatsstreich
gestellt wo man steht das mal vor meinte
hamann er wird dafür belohnt werden dass
das ist genau der interessante punkt
wenn man das liest und wenn man das hört
was diese frau sagt dann gehört dieser
mann sofort im knast ich weiß nicht ob
es passieren wird ich glaube amerika ist
so gespalten das wird nicht
funktionieren kann es im gegenteil das
dass sie angst haben wahrscheinlich dass
tatsächlich zu machen aus angst sie
bringen die menschen noch mehr auf
ja alles alles katastrophe ja gut jetzt
kann man sagen usa sind dem stärkeren
maße ein abstiegs gesellschaft als wir
das sind einfach weiß ich auch nicht das
soziale netz haben
und man muss ja immer sehr vorsichtig
sein
wirtschaftsstatistik über
bruttoinlandsprodukt sagt nichts über
einzelschicksale aus uns richtig in die
angst alle abgehängt und weiß sicher
intensiv genug damit beschäftigt ist in
den usa deutlich höher und abgehängt zu
sein bedeutet auch in den usa etwas ganz
anderes als grund
ein land wo man sich ebenfalls größte
sorgen machen muss frankreich richtig
also auch das ist letztlich eine
abschieds gesellschaft nicht wenn man
auf die reihen wirtschaftskennzahlen
guckt aber wenn man guckt darauf wie
viele leute da mittlerweile von der
mittelschicht in die unterschicht
durchgereicht worden sind auch wenn die
nicht zu unterschätzen die ganzen
spannungen zwischen bio franzosen und
migranten das ist eine gesellschaft der
der soziale kitt in frankreich ist viel
viel schlechter als in deutschland und
ich denke mal man kann die befürchtung
haben dass das die letzte wahl war in
der nicht marine le pen präsidentin
geworden ist alles dinge wo man das
gefühl hat da wird erst mal nichts
besser genau deswegen heute mal so ein
bisschen der der der größere blick hat
und auch so es wichtig finde ich das
noch mal zu erklären was da am sechsten
januar in amerika passiert ist wie
fragil unser system tatsächlich ist und
das ist ja auch glaube ich dass was
zeitenwende meint ja wenn man das immer
so sagt mittlerweile ist das fast so
eine phrase verkommen aber eigentlich
heißt es wieder da der krachen jetzt
systeme gegeneinander und wir sind als
als demokratien da ziemlich
angreifbar wenn man es nicht gut meint
wie offenbar trump und seine leute dann
kann man das sehr schnell unterwandern
und unterhöhlen und kann sozusagen das
eigene system ins wanken bringen und
deswegen richard würde ich gerne gab in
dieser woche viele schlagzeilen an denen
du nicht ganz unbeteiligt war es mit dir
einmal über diesen appell sprechen den
er veröffentlicht habt und den du auch
mit unterzeichnet hat okra ihnen mein
gefühl ist und hier wirklich lange was
wochenende auch darüber nachgedacht mein
gefühl ist tatsächlich dass ihr da
falsch liegt und zwar deswegen weil ich
glaube dass in der ukraine unter anderem
genau das gerade verhandelt wird worüber
wir hier reden wie ernst ist uns unser
gerede über unsere werte über unsere
liberale demokratie ich glaube dass ich
länder auf der ganzen welt gerade ganz
genau anschauen wie wir uns dazu
verhalten ob wie die ukraine jetzt im
stich lassen um es mal ganz platt zu
formulieren oder aus deren sicht zu
formulieren oder ob wir ernsthaft die
wirklich bei ihrem heldenhaften versuch
unterstützen sich selbst zu verteidigen
und damit auch unsere eigene freiheit zu
verteidigen
ich hatte am vergangenen donnerstag eine
beeindruckende begegnung mit karl
schlögel den wir hier schon öfter
zitiert haben der historiker der 2015
dieses buch gemacht hat über
über die situation in der ukraine
und wenn du das liest es ist wirklich
bis heute ist eine düstere prophezeiung
hast das gefühl das buch ist gestern
geschrieben unter dem eindruck dieses
angriffs der nimmt dass dort alles
vorweg und sagt wir haben und das hatte
in der sendung sehr eindringlich gesagt
wir haben noch gar nicht wirklich
begriffen worum es hier eigentlich
wirklich geht hier geht es nicht um ein
paar quadratkilometer ukraine sondern
hier geht es tatsächlich um den versuch
den ganzen kontinent auf den kopf zu
stellen und die werden erst aufhören
wenn sie militärisch besiegt sind welche
beweise hat herr schlegel für diese
these die ich in der früh für eine
verschönerung erzählung hat also okay
das ist jetzt meine verschwörungs
erzählung er sagte nur sein satz ist der
satz der sich so an geprägt hat wir
wissen noch gar nicht wirklich wo mit
bisher eigentlich zu tun haben und da
gut ich denke mal dass aldi die menschen
die das beobachten die geheimdienstleute
all die politologen aldi osteuropa
expertin und so weiter die sich an
dieser frage übrigens völlig uneinig
sind das muss noch mal sagen da gibt es
hier nicht die meinung also nach wie vor
ist es ja eine der
größten
ausdeutung des orakels von delphi mit
wissen zu wollen was ganz ganz genau bei
dem putin denkt und bis wohin er gehen
will und dass seine ziele sind und so
das wissen wir ja alles nach wie vor
nicht da stehen ja ganz viele deutungen
meistens alles von leuten die ihn nie
getroffen haben nie mit ihm darüber
geredet haben im raum
deswegen bin ich bei diesen prognosen
ganz vorsichtig und sage ich weiß das
nicht
sondern was du gesagt hast diese
gesinnungsethik appell ja hier geht es
ums ganze hier geht es um unsere werte
wir können das nicht durchgehen lassen
und so weiter diese frage hat sich
eigentlich erledigt und die hat sich
deswegen erledigt weil wir inzwischen
sehr genau begriffen haben dass dieser
krieg für die ukraine nicht gewinnbar
ist wenn er gewinnbar wäre dann stünden
wir tatsächlich vor der frage was sind
wir bereit zu investieren
für das was sie auf dem spiel steht wenn
ich aber militärisch sagen muss ist es
eine frage der zeit beim der krieg
verloren geht und je länger er dauert
umso mehr unheil richtet er an und zwar
eben schlimmerweise nicht nur in der
ukraine ich meine jetzt nicht nur tote
ukrainische toto russische soldaten tote
zivilisten leute die ihre
existenzgrundlage verlieren junge leute
die in den krieg gezwungen werden und
ihr gesicht weggeschossen kriegen gräber
in denen vielleicht nur eine hand oder
fuß liegt ja jeden tag geht es weiter
und weiter und weiter und parallel dazu
steigt das risiko dass nach einem
vorstellungen die uno entwickelt hat
nicht nur hunderttausende sondern
vielleicht millionen menschen in afrika
verhungern werden und jeder kriegstag
bringt dieses szenario immer näher das
ist neben dem was du gesagt ich kann das
ja nachvollziehen was du sagst ist ja
nicht so als ob ich da jetzt mit deiner
überzeugung ein problem hätte ich sage
nur die frage hier eine entscheidung
herbei zu zwingen zwischen der freiheit
des westens auf der einen seite und den
autokratischen machtansprüchen russlands
auf der anderen seite wo man nicht
nachgeben darf diese frage stellt sich
gar nicht mehr weil sich die frage nicht
mehr stellte ob man den krieg gewinnt ja
aber jetzt gilt es geht um
schadensbegrenzung
das ist das worum es jetzt geht der
schaden ist da der schaden wird groß
sein es wird kein verhandlungsergebnis
geben dass dir gefällt oder das mir
gefällt aber die frage ist wenn der
krieg noch länger geht dann gibt es ein
noch schlimmeres verhandlungsergebnisse
und das ist der grund wir beide
voneinander abweichen genau in der
gesinnung nein nicht in der gesehen
sondern in der einschätzung ob die
fortsetzung des krieges letztlich mehr
gutes bringt oder mehr übles bringt und
da bin ich eindeutig auf der seite des
üblen du hast du hast vorhin gesagt die
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die ukraine
ihr habt diesen appell veröffentlicht
nur juli zeh du und andere svenja
flaßpöhler ist auch dabei
waffenstillstand jetzt und du sagtest
gerade die ukraine macht muss nichts
vorhaben ja auch letztes mal schon sehr
ausführlich darüber gesprochen ist dabei
diesen krieg zu verlieren und
tatsächlich wenn man sich die fakten
anguckt würde man sagen auf den ersten
blick ihr habt völlig recht die ukraine
hat munitionsvorräte faktisch
aufgebraucht pro tag sterben im moment
etwa 100 bis 200 ukrainische soldaten
500 verliert die armee durch verwundung
das heißt in den letzten zwei wochen
sind allein über 7.000 ukrainische
soldaten verwundet worden und an die
2.000 soldaten gefallen und das macht
natürlich auch was mit der psyche der
überlebenden diese armee sind ungefähr
noch 30.000 mann dazu kommt wenn man
sich mal die zahlen anschaut die russen
haben so viel so massiv artillerie dass
auf dieser frontlinie von 1300
kilometern steht glaube ich alle 50
meter ungefähr also jetzt statistisch
einen geschützt die setzten am tag
zwischen 20 und 30 tausend
artilleriegranaten 1 und dem können die
ukraine zwischen 5 bis
600 entgegensetzen obwohl sie fünf bis
sechstausend bräuchte und markus markus
ich weiß ich weiß was für dich das
problem ist und ich kann es absolut
nachvollziehen es ist die kapitulation
dafür dass jemand brutal mit dem recht
des stärkeren sich herausholt was ihm
nicht zusteht und dafür bereit es einen
gigantischen blut zurückzuzahlen und die
entrüstung darüber die teile ich mit ja
ich war ja machen es nicht besser wenn
wir die realität nicht einsehen ich habe
mir weißt du wenn wir das mal auf ne auf
eine größere ebene heben richard es gibt
ein paar dinge in dem zusammenhang und
deswegen glaube ich dass wir an so einem
fundamentalen punkt sind die mir einfach
angst machen weißt du was eigentlich der
aller der mais geteilten hashtags im
moment in indien ist
stand mit putin stand with russia dieser
vollkommen auf der seite russlands diese
ganze erzählung funktioniert es fahren
im moment
irrsinnig viele schiffe meistens
übrigens griechische schiffe mit
ausgeschaltetem gps damit man sie nicht
orten kann fahren über die weltmeere
transportieren sozusagen illegal und und
gegen die sanktionen russisches öl nach
indien und nach indonesien das wird dann
dort raffiniert in den in den
raffinerien sagen sie die inder sagen
nicht ganz genau was da eigentlich
wirklich alles drin ist was ist eine
erklärung warum das so ist ich glaube
das hat damit zu tun dass sich diese
länder unter kommen zb auch zu afrika
sehr genau angucken wie viel unser
gerede über westliche werte und über
moral wie viel uns das eigentlich
tatsächlich wert ist wie ich glaube ich
war ja ganz gut wie überhaupt nicht wie
erwartet ganz kurz es gab interessante
begegnungen ja der südafrikanische
präsident zum beispiel ja der jetzt auch
bei g7 dabei waren so weiter das sind
alles leute die haben ein problem mit
uns der senegalesische präsident der
putin besucht hat ja putin besucht hatte
aber in der ukraine noch nie war aktuell
vorsitzender der afrikanischen union ja
die halten uns für scheinheilig weil wir
so viele kriege so viele konflikte in
afrika zb die haben uns nie wirklich
interessiert der ganze kontinent hat uns
nie wirklich in erst jetzt statt dessen
haben wir zugesehen wie die chinesen
dort wirklich das ding von hinten
aufgerollt haben und das geschäft
gemacht haben und den einfach dabei sind
wir kommen immer mit moral wir kommen
mit unseren idealen und die chinesen
liefern bagger und sie liefern im
zweifel einfach den nächsten brunnen und
helfen den leuten ganz handfest und ganz
konkret sagen passt auf wir knüpfen dass
auch nicht an bestimmte bedingungen
ihr müsst keine demokratischen wahlen
abhalten das muss auch alles nicht
nachhaltig sein da darf auch
kinderarbeit im spiel sein das ist uns
alles völlig egal wir helfen euch ganz
simpel ganz praktisch mit infrastruktur
und das verfängt wenn du dir das mal
anschauen es gab in dieser woche alle
eine hochinteressante umfrage oder
vielleicht sie sich schon ein paar
wochen alt habe ich gelesen dass das
studenten afrikanische studenten sagen
etwas oft die chinesen stehen vielmehr
in unserer seite als die europäer wenn
die zum studieren gehen ja es gibt kein
einziges afrikanisches land aus dem du
visafrei nach europa beraten nach europa
reisen könnte ist kein einziges ja das
heißt ein afrikanischer student ein
junger afrikaner der was will vom leben
der geht entweder nach china um zu
studieren oder er geht sogar nach saudi
arabien um zu studieren wohin auch immer
er geht auf jeden fall mit größerer
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht nach europa das
heißt unser ganz ist gelaber von von von
von hilfe zur selbsthilfe man all die
ganzen entwicklungshilfe milliarden die
wir die wir geschickt haben und so
weiter wo sind die eigentlich alle
geblieben wir haben korrupte eliten
unterstützer einer letzten jahren immer
weiter es hat uns nur interessiert auch
eigene interessen verfolgt und weiter
ich will man ja in rosenheim jaja darfst
du darfst du noch eine eine sache noch
nur damit das mal klar ist worum es da
geht freunde zu besuch ja das hat der
regionalbeauftragte afrika des
auswärtigen amt ist neulich getwittert
als er eine delegation aus
äquatorial-guinea empfangen hat ja in
berlin freunde zu besuch ich meine das
ist äquatorial guinea ist
notorisch furchtbar regiert und kurt bis
zum gehtnichtmehr plumpe wahlfälschungen
das ganze thema wir lassen uns mit
diesen leuten fotografieren wie hofieren
die geknüpften das nicht wirklich an
bedingungen sondern lassen dass einfach
alles geschehen und das ist der grund
warum junge leute in afrika wenn man sie
fragt was braucht ihr eigentlich dann
sagen die na ja was wir vor allem
bräuchten wir eigentlich mal ein
stabiles stromnetz wasser und und und
vielleicht mal eine straße über die man
fahren kann ohne dass man ständig sich
die achse nach seinem klein lkw oder
einem kleinlaster bricht wo sind diese
ganzen entwicklungshilfe milliarden
wohin sind die heilig versichert und das
ist einer der gründe und sich das mal
anschaut wie sich die afrikaner zum
beispiel auch wirklich eigentlich gegen
uns wenn die stellen sich geht und zwar
die frage ist warum tun die das deswegen
glaube ich dass wir jetzt endlich mal
wir müssen jetzt mal farbe bekennen und
wir müssen jetzt mal
zudem stehen wofür wir angeblich immer
so sind nämlich für unsere moral und
unsere werte so ziemlich auf also ganz
viel stoff auf einem heim ich versuche
es nicht ganz so lang zu machen nein
nicht der hauptgrund warum die warum die
inder die russen unterstützungen die
chinesen auch ist weil sie ein interesse
am ende der pax americana haben das hat
aber gar nichts mit werten zu tun das
hat was mit einfluss zu tun also im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert da muss
man kein prophet sein wird china noch
bedeutender werden indien wird noch sehr
viel bedeutender werden die bedeutung
amerikas und europas werden kleiner
werden so daran haben diese staaten
volkswirtschaften mit über eine
milliarde menschen ein ganz vitales
interesse dass das genauso ist wie sagen
wir sind die bevölkerungsreichsten
länder der welt und das ist das
naheliegendste von der welt und das
müssen wir auch um diese bevölkerung zu
sättigen ja und um dieser bevölkerung
eine perspektive zu geben müssen wir
eigentlich die dominierenden nationen
auf diesem planeten sein und deswegen
haben sie ohne innere sympathie mit
russland ein weil die ich meine da gab
es - besonders festes band aber ein
interesse daran dass der westen sich an
russland die zähne ausbeißt das hat mit
werten das interessiert dann ist
überhaupt nicht das ist die erste und
die zweite antwort ist der westen hat
immer in seiner gesamten geschichte zu
sein werden ein ambivalentes verhältnis
genau wie die usa haben mit dem hinweis
auf menschenrechte ja haben sie im
kalten krieg
gepunktet gegen die sowjetunion sie
haben aber gleichzeitig in südamerika
kinos unterstützt ja in chile ein dealer
in argentinien ein schlosser in paraguay
und so weiter sie haben also jedes
erdenkliche unrechtsregime haben sie
gestützt sie haben militärputsche gegen
demokratische gewählte regierungen
angezettelt usw als krasses der
gegenteil der eigentlich vertretenen
werte und gegenüber afrika waren wir
genauso man darf ja nicht vergessen was
den anderen etwas den afrikanern in den
knochen steckt ist es war nicht die
chinesen die ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts als sich die länder unter
nagel gerissen aufgeteilt haben und
künstliche grenzen geschaffen habe und
man denkt mal an die gräuel die die
belgier im kongo gemacht haben
unvorstellbare verbrechen
das ist die soziale schlechtesten
erfahrungen die die afrikaner je gemacht
haben in ihrer ganzen geschichte haben
sie mit europäischen gemacht
und die europäer haben seit den 50er
60er jahren geht ich gesehen dass quasi
da
nichts mehr zu gewinnen haben die die
kolonien aufgegeben haben aber immer
noch wahnsinniger einfluss darauf
genommen zum beispiel das apartheid
regime in südafrika weiterhin
unterstützt auch gegen die eigenen wert
also wir haben da keine gute geschichte
das muss man als erstes sagen und das
ist den afrikanern sehr gut bewusst
jetzt gehörig zu denjenigen die seit
mindestens zehn jahren sagen die
wichtigsten zukunftsfragen werden
tatsächlichen afrika sicher weil durch
den klimawandel bedingt irgendwann sich
nicht millionen sondern eine milliarde
menschen auf die socken machen muss und
sei es in 10 20 oder 30 jahren um anders
hinzugehen weil dass der kontinent in
weiten teilen nicht mehr bewohnbar ist
einmal dadurch dass die millionenstädte
wie lagers die direkt am äquator liegen
in den fluten versinken oder in anderen
regionen fällt kein tropfen regen das
andere ist das dann natürlich sehr viele
bodenschätze sind zum beispiel die wir
für unsere elektromobilität brauchen
also bald um coltan als bekannteste
beispiele im budget sind in der
zentralafrikanischen republik die sind
im kongo also in den schlimmsten der
schlimmen länder freunde zu besuch sagt
wer freunde zu besuchen so und jetzt
habe ich gesagt schon vor langer zeit
wieso haben wir eigentlich ein
außenministerium warum ist das nicht ein
ministerium für globale zusammenarbeit
müssen sie nicht die hauptaufgabe von
annalena baerbock der haut darin liegen
ja also in den richtig ganz großen
zukunftsherausforderungen
nämlich das war ein gutes verhältnis zu
den afrikanischen ländern bekommt und
dass man effektive hilfe leistet wie die
chinesen das auch tun und ich habe
meinen vorschlag gemacht er angeregt
wurde nach einem langen gespräch mit
rupert neudeck rupert neudeck gehört zu
den menschen die ich am stärksten
bewundere den ich je begegnet bin
rupert neudeck ist der mann der die cap
anamur dieses schiff
gekauft geleast oder sowas hat und hat
damit die boatpeople vor wir haben aus
dem wasser gezogen also die leute die
vor der kommunistische regierung
geflohen sind und
hat denen geholfen und zehntausende von
menschen allen lesern im ozean
untergegangen wären aufgenommen das war
damals übrigens alles illegal ja und er
hat es einfach aus rein humanistischen
motive ausgemacht ein mann dem
zehntausende von menschen ihr leben
verdanken und er hat im hinblick auf
afrika angeregt sozusagen
entwicklungshilfe wie wir das bisher
machen es blödsinn ja verteilen damit
der gießkanne was man kann auch hier mal
ein brunnen bauen und da mal eine schule
und dann gibt es einen systemwechsel ja
und dann gibt es gleich wieder
bürgerkrieg und damit das wird sowieso
wird verbrannt und vergiftet er hat
gesagt jedes europäische land müsste
sich als partner einem anderen
afrikanischen land anbieten eine ja also
ich sofort da wir jetzt vorhat ein
grüner trainiert jetzt würde man sagen
was dann als sanierer zweimal deutsche
kolonie tanganjika und so weiter die
deutschen ich war in tansania haben ein
exzellent beruf ist agrana wie fast
überall wir zum beispiel sehr wesentlich
für die medizinische versorgung in
diesem land sorgen ja wenn man dort
gemeinsame kabinettssitzungen macht
nicht als kolonialherr sondern als
ermöglicher ja also das bespricht und
sagt das habt ihr vor ja und wir haben
hier ingenieure es geht ja nicht nur ums
geld man muss ja auch die leute haben
die das alles machen umbauen können usw
wenn man das quasi machen würde und 2
sozusagen als reparation für die
kolonialzeit ja jetzt kommen wir als
freunde jetzt helfen wir euch ihr seid
was für euch wichtig ist und wir helfen
euch dabei
das wäre eine großartige idee gewesen
dass in diese richtung zu machen aber
alles was die eu macht marshalls überall
afrika und sekretärin ganze riecht immer
diese riesige inbegriffen
ländern enthält verteilt und wer weiß wo
es ankommt ja also das was was braucht
es die persönliche ebene ja also dieses
gefühl ihr gehört zu uns in dem sinne
für für wir wollen euch helfen und du
weißt ja ich bin ja für dieses
gesellschaft ja ich stelle mir vor wie
menschen die vorher ärzte waren die oder
geht natürlich immer noch ärzte sind mit
65 oder sowas und krankenhaus geleitet
habe mal für ein jahr darunter gehen ja
dass uns die ganzen ingenieure
deutschland hat ja nun mit die besten
ingenieure der welt wenn die man im jahr
dort sind und einfach mal gucken was
kann man machen was kann man aufbauen
und zwar nicht einzelne sondern tausende
und abertausende man kann so viel gutes
auf dieser ebene machen und das wäre
eine wichtige perspektive und wir
bräuchten ein außenministerium dass
diese sache zur wichtigsten frage
erklärt genau aber du hast es eben
gerade gesagt vor zehn jahren hast du
angefangen dir solche gedanken zu machen
und da war glaube ich auch der zeitpunkt
ich meine noch vor wenigen jahren
tatsächlich keine 20 jahre her und war
china in afrika kein großer wichtiger
player seitdem hat sich das alles
fundamental auf den kopf gestellt und
wichtig eben sagt er wir kommen immer
dann mit mit großen idealen und knüpfen
dann die die frage ob wir handel treiben
oder nicht an ganz bestimmte moralische
bedingungen und jetzt bei den g7 gerade
wieder 600 milliarden
infrastrukturprogramm und so weiter für
den globalen süden wenn du mal genau
hinguckt verteilt auf fünf bis sechs
jahre kriegt man so das ist das was bei
g7 immer passiert riesige summen riesige
ankündigungen nichts dahinter und ich
sicherlich der wind der wintrich hat hat
sich wirklich gedreht es gab vor ein
paar wochen gab es in amerika gipfel
weiß nicht ob das mitgekriegt hat joe
biden der hat venezuela
kuba und nicaragua nicht ganz einfache
länder ausgeladen von diesem
amerika-gipfel weil die politik dieser
länder nicht demokratischen werten
entsprechen
das ist richtig also befund aber
interessant war was daraufhin passiert
ist daraufhin hat der präsident von
mexiko bolivien uruguay honduras el
salvador und guatemala und jetzt im wald
durch mit mit südamerika aus
lateinamerika auch abgesagt dem einfach
haben gesagt ja weil das vorhandene
fadenscheinig ist da wir haben beispiel
von äquatorial-guinea erzählte es gibt
länder da sonst völlig egal ob dass
demokratien sind oder nicht und da gibt
andere die sind unsere traditionellen
systemen feinde die kuba zum beispiel
was jetzt politisch nicht zu den
schlimmsten ländern der welt gehört also
nicht wieder kongo oder sowas soll keine
barbarischen starken aber mit dem kongo
wollen wir geschäfte machen wir brauchen
das konnten wir brauchen das kobalt für
unsere batterien genau so ist es ja aber
wenn du wenn du musst mir überlegen es
ist also auch mit blick auf die kokain
über die wir gerade eben schon
diskutiert haben der mexikanische
präsident opera dorn hat die die
westlichen waffenlieferungen an die
kräne als unmoralisch verurteilt
ein zweiter teil kein einziges land in
lateinamerika
beteiligt sich an den sanktionen gegen
russland und jetzt kommt's spornte auch
kein einziges land aus afrika kein
einziges ja aber in den hasen aber es
ist nur japanische und hat er wird der
senegalesische präsident eingeladen er
soll bei den g7 jetzt sozusagen ein
kopfnicken und die den kurs ja den
zeitenwende kurs gegenüber russland
mittragen in afrika sterben pro tag
25.000 menschen an hunger ja ungefähr so
viele wie vielleicht russische oder
ukrainische soldaten insgesamt in diesem
krieg bisher gefallen sind in vier
monaten die sterbende an einem tag
wir haben ganz andere sorgen jaja für
die ist der ukraine krieg so wichtig wie
für uns ein krieg zwischen angola und
namibia gut es gibt karten wusstest du
dass es aktuell einen nennen wir es
konflikt wie es immer so schön heißt in
kamerun gibt
so wie ich auch nicht jetzt in der
beschäftigung vom letzten wochen
irgendwo tauchte das dann immer mal auf
wenn man sich mal mit afrika beschäftigt
in kamerun gibt es gerade kunst liegt
nur daran wie viele male wie viele
deutsche haben in den letzten sieben
jahren ja irgendeine vorstellung davon
gehabt dass
300.000 menschen im jemen in folge des
krieges ein stellvertreterkrieg zwischen
iran und saudi arabien gestorben sind
wie oft tauchte dieser krieg in unseren
medien auf wieviel jemenitische fahnen
hast du irgendwo gesehen und da ist
richtig es ist für uns ein großer
unterschied ob die leute uns ähnlich
sehen ob die nah dran sind und ob wir
für persönlichen sicherheitspolitische
interessen damit verbinden und im jemen
es uns ist ziemlich egal am ende ob die
saudis gewinnen oder ob die iraner
gewinnen abgesehen davon dass wir gute
geschäfte namen machen dass wir den
saudis auch noch waffen verkaufen genau
deswegen meine ich diese rhetorik ne
wenn du dir auch mal vielleicht noch mal
an an bogen zur eu immer eine die
europäische union wir beschwören gerade
die europäische union und dann wird dann
gesagt ja wenn putin 1 erreicht hat dann
dass der westen was auch immer dann der
westen ist ja mal darüber gesprochen wer
sich mittlerweile alles anders definiert
die die europäische union steht steht so
eng zusammen wie schon lange nicht mehr
ganz ehrlich die europäische union ist
in einem bedauernswerten zustand hat
praktisch keinen einfluss mehr auf die
türkei
dann gab es gratis im desaströsen gipfel
was den westbalkan betrifft kleine
länder die alle seit 20 jahren in die eu
wollen nix wir haben keinen wirklichen
einfluss auf tunesien wo die demokratie
gerade wirklich auch auf der kippe steht
wir haben keinen wirklichen einfluss im
kaukasus auf den iran im krieg zwischen
aserbaidschan und armenien damir
zugeguckt da war einfach zuschauer ja
also wenn wir es nicht mal schaffen in
ländern die direkt an die eu kann
grenzen ja die uns unmittelbar betreffen
einfluss zu nehmen dann denke ich immer
ja was zur hölle waren wir dem rest der
welt ausrichten was was was was wollen
wir eigentlich wollen wir eine richtige
wieder am anfang des gesprächs wir sind
nicht so stark wie wir denken und eine
wichtige wichtige quintessenz dieser
zeitenwende zeit ist dass wir jetzt
erkennen an rissen die die erde aufweist
dass sich die platten ja schon vorher
verschoben haben ja also viele der dinge
die über die wir heute reden ich sehe
noch helmut schmidt vor zehn jahren 15
jahren in talkshows sitzen und über die
wachsende bedeutung chinas erzählen über
das ende der vormachtstellung des
westens
jetzt wird das sichtbarer also der
ukraine krieg hat einen riss aufgemacht
wo wir gehen deutlich sehen dass das was
wir so als liberal globalisierte welt
betrachtet haben bei näherem hinsehen
etwas ganz ganz anderes ist wir haben
aus einer vielzahl eurozentrischen
perspektive auf die welt geschaut habe
es viel zu sehen alles einfach unseren
maßstäben gemessen und müssen jetzt
quasi sehen wir sind mehr sie dieser
dämliche satz von annalena baerbock na
wo sie es am nächsten tag in einer neuen
welt aufgewacht nach dem russischen
überfall diese welt diese welt war schon
vorher ganz anders an hat sich schon
ganz oft verschoben trotzdem kann
nämlich uns hat doch ich finde den satz
dämlich weil ja was eigentlich ein
brutaler fürchterlicher krieg aber es
ist wahrlich nicht der erste gute alle
fürchterliche krieg die das in den
letzten jahrzehnten erschüttert aber was
ist passiert meint genau das was wir
gerade besprochen haben das tatsächlich
unsere welt jetzt eine andere ist und
dass werner dem fundamentalen wendepunkt
an gekommen sind das hat finde ich
annalena baerbock im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen sehr genau verstanden sie hat in
dem moment einfach eine andere welt ist
eine welt in der ein autokrat und
aggressor in europa ein krieg beginnt
sie hat damit nicht gemeint dass wir
jetzt das ende der pax americana erleben
das hat sie mit keiner silbe irgendwo je
gesagt sondern sie hat eigentlich die
klassische west sicht ja die du auch
vorhin vertreten hast und dir nicht
nachvollziehbar ist ja wir können um
unsere werte willen und so weiter das
nicht durchgehen lassen das ist
eigentlich ihr thema und ich meine dass
wir diese sicht so verständlich sie ist
nicht aufrechterhalten können weil sie
realpolitische geholt wird
ja das ist wahr es gibt du kennst
margrethe vestager kennst du die nicht
persönlich aber nicht aber die
kommissare genau genau
wahnsinnig interessante politische figur
sozusagen hat sich mit den gasen mal
groß angelegten genau mit den digital
corp
jemand den ich sehr haltbare den erlaube
ich mir eine denen genau genau die hat
dieser tage was total interessantes
gesagt die sagte ein großer teil der
europäischen industrie basiert auf
billige energie aus russland auf billige
arbeitskraft aus china unter hochs
hochsubventionierten halbleitern aus
teil waren und dann weiter wir waren
nicht naiv wir waren gierig das ist sehr
weise ja was der punkt aber wir waren
nicht gierig weil wir böse sind löhne
sondern weil wir unsere daten schlicht
und wohlstandes erzählung zu ja genau
das ist der nächsten generation noch
besser gehen soll und dass er immer
wachstum versprechen müssen und so
weiter wir sind verdammt dazu in diesem
sinne gierig zu sein weil unser
wirtschaftssystem so funktioniert und
weil unsere gesellschaften sofort
das stimmt
zum schluss ich habe das wird sich
vielleicht als als philosoph freuen ich
habe dieser tage und ich glaube es war
kalt schüttelt er mich darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat einen total interessanten
satz von ernst bloch
gelesen oder einen gedanken der
sozusagen darauf hinweist dass man die
vergangenheit durchaus irgendwie
analysieren und verstehen kann und man
kann auch letzten endes die zukunft
relativ gut sich anschauen in jeder
wendung sie auf jeden fall ausmalen man
kann sich szenarien hinlegen und
überlegen wie wird das morgen wohl sein
aber bloch war offenkundig der meinung
dass das schwierigste die schwierigste
ebene des verstehens die gegenwart ist
ja nicht die vergangenheit sondern die
gegenwart und er nannte es das dunkel
des gelebten augenblicks das fand ich
total trinken also dachte ja genau das
ist genau das das ist die situation in
der wir gerade ja das ist schön das ist
der richtige satz für die gegenwart ja
also noch nie war der gelebte augenblick
so dunkel wie im augenblick ja ist doch
so ja es ist so es ist tatsächlich so
ich glaube dass wir ganz große probleme
im augenblick damit haben uns selbst zu
sehen und uns selbst zu verstehen
sondern wir blicken zurück in etwas das
anders war und wir blicken voraus in
etwas von dem wir keine vorstellung
haben es sei denn dystopische bilder
also wir können uns eine welt in der
europa und die usa nicht mehr die
vormachtsstellung haben nicht anders
vorstellen als grottenschlecht und da
muss man sich immer fragen liegt das
daran dass das alles keine
funktionierenden demokratien sind und so
weiter liegt das wirklich daran oder
liegt das daran dass wir uns kein bild
von einer welt machen können und wollen
die mit einem bedeutungsverlust den wir
dabei erleiden eine rinne und vielleicht
ist es eine mischung aus beidem ja
matthias horx habe ich dieser tage
gelesen bin ich auch sehr sehr schätze
liebe grüße an der stelle der sprach von
einer zukunfts verlorenheit
das ist der punkt ja wir wir haben keine
idee mehr keine große innere perspektive
mehr wenn es um die frage geht was ist
eigentlich das was uns an leitet was ist
das was uns treibt so wollen beide ich
hin und das lähmt und sogar fährt hier
eine schöne anekdote zu ein weil das war
in der zeit mitte der neunziger jahre da
hatte ich mal die gelegenheit mit
friedbert pflüger zu reden ja die
älteren erinnern sich der wahl also als
junger wilder der jungen union geht auch
galt er als ganz große nachwuchshoffnung
und wollte später mal regierender
bürgermeister in berlin werden das ist
ziemlich geglückt und so so aber dieser
friedbert pflüger war damals so kommen
der stern in der cdu
und ich bemängelte damals dass nach dem
ende des kalten krieges der westen
eigentlich keine richtige
vision hätte ja also keine utopie naja
wie eine zukünftige welt sein sollen wir
reden jetzt mitte der neunziger jahre
außer einer irgend eines beliebigen
weiter so oder so ja aber es ist würde
doch angesichts der auch in zukunft
aufbrechen und probleme einer utopie
bedürfen die über unseren dunstkreis
hinaus geht also nur utopie quasi wie
sich der planet entwickeln sollte damals
war da auch die umweltfragen gab es
alles schon die hatten nur nicht dieses
große thema und dann sagte er mir die
einzige utopie die jetzt quasi noch
angemessen sein wäre eine utopie der
utopie losigkeit dh wir sollten das
quasi genießen ja und jetzt keine
falschen oder schrägen utopien mehr zu
machen sondern jetzt wäre alles gut wie
furchtbar und das ist das problem das
ist das nur das nokia problem der westen
hat gedacht da läuft doch alles ja wir
sind die weltmarktführer in fast allem
und jetzt muss alles einfach nur so
bleiben wie es ist und dann kam das
smartphone oder anders ausgedrückt china
und china bleibt nicht alleine was ich
sage aber in ihren maxein indonesien
vielleicht irgendwann der iran ja wenn
er sich von den fesseln seiner mullahs
befreit
alles das können gewaltige länder in der
zukunft werden total und und der der der
kontext ist ja ist ja auch so zu sagen
hatte noch mal andere dimension es gab
ja mal eine zeit fukuyama und so weiter
das ende der geschichte da wurden die
demokratien oder die die liberalen
system auf der welt wohnen ja immer mehr
mittlerweile nehmen sie ganz eindeutig
ab wir haben am beginn darüber
gesprochen wie knapp es davor stand dass
auch die usa sich aus diesem club
verabschiedet hätten ich richtig wie
furchtbar
ich danke dir und an dem punkt noch kurz
der hinweis wir sehen uns nächste woche
mal wieder ein fernsehstudio der sänger
freue ich mich sehr drauf ein solo mit
dir ja habe ich mir immer schon mal
gewünscht und
die hamas sprechen er ist es schon so
weit
[Musik]
eine produktion von m2 und popstars bei
ohren er im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]